my name is Anne White I'm a professor of
nuclear science and engineering at MIT
and I've been challenged today to
explain nuclear fusion in five levels of
increasing difficulty
Fusion is so exciting because it is
extraordinarily beautiful physics which
underpins some of the most basic
processes in our universe nuclear
processes has a tremendously valuable
application for humankind a virtually
Limitless Clean safe carbon-free form of
energy
what's your name tell me a little bit
about yourself I'm Amelia I'm nine years
old I'm a third grade and my favorite
subject at school is definitely science
so my son is five years old and he asked
me what kind of science I do
and I said fusion and I said I put a
star in a jar does that make sense
okay that's a good answer because it
sounds a little ridiculous right how can
we put a star in a jar well we're not
actually going to put the sun which is a
star inside a jar but instead we're
going to take the same kind of material
that the sun is made out of and we're
going to hold it for a really long time
in some kind of container so Fusion is
about bringing things together that's
what fusing means when those Fusion
reactions occur a new particle is
created and energy is also released do
you know what an atom is yeah all right
so Adam is what everything in our world
is made of and at the very center of the
atom is what we call a nucleus and
inside that nucleus is a proton we want
to take those those protons and push
them together to make them combine and
release energy Fusion Energy that we can
use to make electricity and there's a
lot of different energies and forces
that we have to think about have you
heard of gravity yes yes okay so that is
a big important fundamental Force so
another fun Force to talk about that's
important for Fusion you're familiar
with electricity yes right and so
there's also electric forces
electrostatic forces and you've heard of
static electricity so now let's see
about static electricity lifting my hair
up
I can move there's a white strand it's
like hanging down the balloon took on
the force from like your hair and put it
in here now just like move it there you
go yeah and so if we want to take those
those protons and push them together to
make them combine and release energy
Fusion Energy that we can use to make
electricity then we have to actually
overcome that strong electrostatic force
that just want to make those balls
bounce off of each other there's another
Force which you might be familiar with
which is like a magnetic force we're
just learning about our teacher Shield
is putting one magnet on and then
flipping the other one around it made it
the top like kind of Bounce yeah so
thinking on how to do that you know
scientists are still studying exactly
how magnetism works right it'll still be
there for you to tackle when you become
a scientist have you ever seen one of
these games yes with the iron filing so
if you take this and you take the
magnetic end maybe you can show us
what's going to happen with it while you
move around those iron filings with the
magnet you're totally in control of that
material you're pushing you're pulling
it you're moving it around and so you're
using this magnetic force to also do
something useful for you have you
learned about the states of matter yes
tell me about that so great and she put
a picture on the board should you say
tomorrow she shows a picture of ice a
picture of water and a picture of gas
did you learn that there's also a fourth
state of matter no when you heat up a
gas
you create a plasma a plasma is the
fourth state of matter the plasma I
study is actually invisible
I think we heard science yes and the
plasmas I work with are so hot that I
can't see with my eyes but it's light
that I can measure it with very very
special instruments let's
play music
how do you keep the invisible plasmas
yes or invisibility keep them in one
spot so you can show where they are yes
we absolutely do we hold it inside the
container with the magnetic fields so
you didn't have to actually touch the
iron filings in the toy to move them
around
you could pass the magnetic field
through the plastic and control them
with it so it's the same thing we don't
have to touch this very very hot plasma
to control it and hold it in place
because we use magnetic fields you are
so smart I'm so glad that science is
your favorite subject
what is student energy the way our sun
generates energy is by Fusion reactions
it fuses hydrogen the lightest element
we know about into helium and that gets
fused into heavier and heavier elements
so here on Earth we're going to take
some special kinds of hydrogen a special
flavor of it if you will which we call
an isotope and we're going to combine
them to create new particles and we can
only get that combination of particles
to happen if they are in a plasma what's
your favorite exhibit the science museum
I love the lightning show like okay so
cool you probably have learned in school
about three states of matter the solid
liquid and gas absolutely we take the
gas and we add heat and we get a plasma
and a plasma is a state of matter where
you have an ionized gas if we break down
that gas if we add enough energy to
ionize it we can take the electrons and
the ions and the atom and separate them
and now there's this soup of charged
particles that are moving around that's
the plasma and it is what creates the
beautiful light in lightning so you've
already seen a plasma in fact so I'm
going to show you this
fun demonstration you've probably seen
one of these before right oh that's so
cool yeah so the way this is happening
is this glass ball here is a container
for our plasma and we've taken most of
the air out of the container so there's
not a lot of particles inside the glass
ball and very very low temperature
plasma so it's continuously ionizing and
then recombining and becoming neutral
again and we see those energy
transitions as the visible light so if
we're going to put this plasma to use
and do something helpful with it like
maybe make some clean electricity we
would have to control it yeah and
another word for controlling it is
confining it so let me let me turn this
off and set it back down you're probably
wondering what is this thing on this
table it's a model of a Tokamak and
that's the name of the device that I
work on with the goal of creating clean
energy have you played with magnets in
school okay we've learned about the how
it has to be a positive positive and
negative charge and we've done those
things you can like put them with
something in between them and just move
one and the other will always follow
this is all very important to sort of
understand how we would create a
container that would let us hold the
plasma in place and control it have you
ever played around with an electromagnet
in class it's a coil of wire much like
this big red coil of wire right here and
when we push an electrical current
through this wire it creates a magnetic
field that goes around the wire
perpendicular so if you want to know the
direction of the magnetic seal that's
been created by pushing the current
Through the Wire put your thumb in the
direction of the current and then curl
your fingers like this yeah and that's
the right hand rule so if we push the
current this way we're creating a
magnetic field in this perpendicular
Direction so if I drive a current and
this red wire like this which direction
will the magnetic field go
yeah exactly perpendicular and if I
drive the current in this green wire
which direction will it go
exactly yeah the Long Way perpendicular
now this is a bit of a trickier one the
blue wire is going to act like a
transformer action and so by changing
the current in the blue coil we are
going to be able to run a current in
this direction around the Tokamak and
now think back to how the wires worked
if I have a current going like this
where's the magnetic field exactly back
this way the short way around the tokoak
we can now put together the pieces and
understand the three magnetic fields
that we need to confine a plasma in our
Tokamak so our plasma will be inside
this vessel in the shape of a donut what
could the tocamak be used for in like
real life oh Supple address so what we
want to use the Toca mic for in realize
is to confine this super hot plasma and
we're talking a hundred million 150
million degrees because the plasma is so
very hot the particles have enough
energy to interact with one another and
fuse when those Fusion reactions occur
we are releasing energy that's inside
the nucleus and we can harness that
energy to make clean electricity
so what have you heard about Fusion
already before today the impeding joke
is that you know we've looked forward to
Fusion for a long time but you're not
exactly gone in there yet but if we do
ever get there it would solve a lot of
our energy problems in a dramatic way do
you have any idea about any of the
challenges like why has it taken us so
long to get to Fusion making a star
honor at this thought easy so we are
trying to bring a starter works we are
not going to be using hydrogen the way
our star in our solar system our sun
uses hydrogen to make helium and
generates Fusion Energy that way instead
on Earth we're going to be using
isotopes of hydrogen deuterium and
tritium what do you know about charged
particles if I want to try and push too
positively charge particles together two
protons together what do you think is
going to happen they repulse each other
and they don't like being close together
so they push back on that
we're gonna call the pushback is a
coulomb interaction or coulomb Collision
so you can sort of imagine if I were to
take a deuteron and a Triton and so
those are the positively charged ions of
deuterium and tritium and I try and
combine them together those two
positively charged particles just sort
of bounce off of each other so we have
to give them enormous amounts of energy
and it has to do with getting up to very
high temperatures so we're talking about
over 100 million degrees Celsius and we
typically put that into an energy unit
that we use a lot in plasma physics
called an electron volt and so we
describe being up at 100 million degrees
that we're at sort of 15 kiloelectron
volts that's very very hot temperature
but the other thing we need is a lot of
particles that's the density we are able
to combine a deuteron and a Triton in a
fusion reaction at lower temperatures at
lower energies than other fuel this has
to do with some very nice properties of
the deuteron and the Triton that when we
get them close enough to one another to
fuse there's actually a resonance which
is predicted by quantum mechanics and
that really helps have a little bump up
in the cross section for the deuterium
tritium fusion reaction compared to just
hydrogen yes exactly exactly how that
little bump up is good for us because it
means that we have a higher probability
of getting the deuterium and the tritium
to fuse than otherwise at those
manageable temperatures and when we say
manageable for Fusion scientists yeah 50
million 100 million 150 million Celsius
so the problem you described is that we
get to those high temperatures we have
dense plasma but the problem is the
hotter the plasma is the more likely it
is the heat to get sucked out of it by
absolutely yeah absolutely glad that
solved is not saying staying hot enough
for the time we needed to stay we've
come so far in the study of magnetically
confined plasmas which is which is what
I work on that we sort of tamed all the
other types of major instabilities that
would cause loss of the plasma so you
might be asking yourself what is the
energy that's coming out of the fusion
reaction so we've got the deuteron and
we've got the Triton and so they combine
an effusion reaction and that produces a
neutron and a helium nucleus but the
neutron doesn't have any charge yes it
comes out exactly so it comes right out
and it's the kinetic energy of the
neutron and we want it to interact with
our overall Energy System and as it
interacts with that material it heats
the material up it transfers is its
kinetic energy to this material take
that thermal energy and run a turbine
run a generator and convert it into
electricity so once you get to that
stage it starts to look a lot like any
other thermal power plant whether it's
fission or natural gas so a fusion plant
could basically be the plasma core
coming in setting it in place and
driving your thermal system to make
electricity we often call it an alpha
particle and that is a charged particle
right so it's actually going to stay in
the plasma it's an energetic particle
compared to the fuel so it actually is
going to
give its kinetic energy back to the fuel
via coulomb collisions cool so now
they're good now we like them so you get
this kind of self-sustaining it's like
yes you said exactly the right word
self-sustaining
I am in soft condensed matter physics
and my research kind of dips into
Material Science but I feel like people
are always asking me about Fusion what
are they asking you about Fusion so
usually people ask me like do you think
that we'll ever really replace all of
our other energy sources with Fusion I
think that it actually has a lot of
mystery around it because the fuel for
Fusion is a plasma and we don't
experience plasmas on Earth in our
everyday life they exist in space at the
Event Horizon of a black hole and the
solar wind in our sun or very rapid
events like lightning is also sort of a
weakly ionized plasma even among plasmas
there are so many different kinds of
plasmas there are low temperature higher
density plasmas there are of course the
astrophysical plasmas and space plasmas
and then there are Fusion plasmas they
are predominantly fully ionized size
plasmas they are also plasmas where we
have a certain ability to basically kick
up micro instabilities so they're
plasmas which are held in a stable
enough state by strong external magnetic
fields confining the plasma into a donut
shape and this has a lot of advantages
for us because charged particles want to
follow the magnetic field lines but
things start to get really interesting
when we're no longer thinking about
individual particle motions in the
plasma and instead we start to think
about Collective effects it's never
occupied any space in my mind to think
about what happens when you have
something so high temperature and like
precisely confined and now you have to
deal with presumably turbulence plus
magnetic fields when we start thinking
about turbulence in the plasma we can no
longer even think about the plasma as a
single fluid instead we have to consider
electron fluid and ion fluid separately
we have to use our full-blown kinetic
equation to explain how this state of
matter is behaving because we have
collisions so we have to add collisions
back in to understand and track how all
the particles are moving and how these
Collective motions as turbulence can get
kicked up so that's pretty intractable
uh yeah right I mean if people talk
about stimulating that system and
following those particles it's probably
going to take millions and millions of
years on even the fastest supercomputer
so one really big advance in plasma
Theory over the last I'd say three or
four decades has been the development of
a gyrokinetic theory that we use to
model the microtubulence in the plasma
and get that under control and the
reason it's so important to get the
turbulence under control and understand
it is because turbulence is the primary
heat loss mechanism the primary way that
heat is transported from hot to cold
across confining field lines in a
magnetic confinement system being able
to study it measure it and predict how
it's going to behave is really one of
the big hurdles to to overcome could you
say the name of the model again
absolutely so it's a gyrokinetic model
and we talked about how challenged it
would be to follow every particle in
space and know its position and know its
velocity at all times so what
gyrokinetics actually does as a theory
is it takes advantage of the fact that
when we drop a Charged particle into a
strong external magnetic field the
Lorenz Force bends that particle's
trajectory into a helix and so now if we
know that wherever the field line is
going that particle is following it in
this helical in this Corkscrew
trajectory we can say aha I no longer
have to worry about following that
particle's velocity around in a circle
because at every point in time I know
it's going in a circle okay so we
average that out we do a row average
because the motion is typically called a
gyro frequency that's how fast it goes
around the field line and it has a
particular radius of that Helix called
the gyro radius because it's just
gyrating so what we know from studying
the plasma and making direct
measurements of the turbulence and also
what comes from the simulations is the
scale size of the turbulence is about 5
to 10 gyro radii use of the density and
temperature fluctuations are what Drive
these uh these turbulent flows that end
up reducing your your heat transport is
there anything that can be done to
minimize the density and heat
fluctuations or is that just like down
to the statistics of things I love the
way you framed it because originally
like in the 60s and 70s people did not
think that microtubulence would even be
a problem but as we started to make more
and more measurements and build higher
and higher basically performing devices
we started to see nothing is matching
the expected performance and that's
because people thought that coulomb
collisions between the particles just
interactions of charged particles would
dominate Cross Field transport right
what happens with turbulence is it
enhances the transport of particles
because now we're not just talking about
this random walk of collisions we're
talking about conduction convection
deities structures microstructures flow
generation very complex soup of activity
turbulence for me like really
hits on one of the most beautiful Parts
about physics like it's so complex and
that's what makes it like visually
beautiful that's what makes it
mathematically interesting and it's also
what keeps us so puzzled about it yeah
turbulence is beautiful and so fun to
study
I'm a research scientist at MIT and I
work on computational plasma physics
basically doing simulations that can
accurately describe what's going on
inside these Fusion reactors like
tokamax and distillerators they have
plasmas that are magnetically confined
so we're trying to predict how the
plasma behaves so that we can build in
the future better reactors what's one of
the most exciting parts of your research
right now something that we were not
able to do until very recently was
actually using first principle
simulations to predict the performance
and efficiency of reactors the
developments in plasma Theory and
computation and simulation and that has
been thoroughly validated over the years
in many experiments that now we're using
those simulations to inform how to best
operate our future reactors very
exciting because so far we've been
getting great results it's very very
promising we're going with a lot of the
experiments right now is trying to
produce some maybe outside the box data
sets that we haven't seen before and
then of course ultimately compare them
to the simulations and do a bit of this
validation maybe where we're not just
looking under the lamp post where we're
going a little bit outside the comfort
zone that means going from measurements
really sort of more in the middle of the
plasma at about mid-radius pushing all
the way out to the edge where the
turbulence starts to become very
different in its nature it becomes a lot
more electromagnetic it becomes
sometimes larger in scale just physical
scale size and some of the things we're
starting to find was that turbulence
features and turbulence characteristics
in the edge of some of these high
performance plasmas
don't always behave the way we think
they do so as we think about pushing our
measurements and our study of the
turbulence from the core to the edge
how does that influence what you're
working on now the edge of the plasmic
gives you the boundary condition really
for the simulations that then we do in
the chord you need to start somewhere
determining what is the temperature very
close to the wall really the machine and
when you get that temperature then you
can actually integrate inwards with the
rest of core model it's going to be very
exciting the next years when we can
actually make some measurements in those
devices and compare them to simulations
so that we can have more trust in the
predictions for the next step for the
reactors the power plants maybe both of
us in our own way answer the question
that we always get asked when is Fusion
gonna happen when are we going to have
Fusion electricity on the grids it's
hard to say when it's gonna arrive I
think that with the arrival of private
companies and Venture Capital
um that is accelerating things a lot so
I don't think Fusion is 30 years away
and it will always be I don't think
that's true anymore so you're saying
lots of private companies have have
entered and that's injected a lot of
private funding not just Government
funding oh yeah the nature of the
private Ventures is you know you want to
get commercial as soon as possible so I
think they're accelerating things they
are actually taking
um advantages of discoveries in other
fields like in the case of
um High field fusion with Commonwealth
Fusion systems and to come back energy
those companies they are using high
temperature superconductors it's an
advancement that has come recently from
material sign right or machine learning
activity telling you those breakthroughs
in other fields I think can really
accelerate Fusion so I think we're
seeing the next decades are going to be
very exciting we have to diversify the
different research that we do so that at
the end we come with the most Optimum
solution for our fusion power plants I
agree yeah I think having multiple
stakeholders who are all driven by
different missions and different
purposes working synergistically is
exciting when I'm asked like okay what's
the timeline for fusion and why is now
any different than five years ago or ten
years ago why is now the Walmart for
Fusion my answer is it's finally for the
first time all the pieces of the puzzle
are here we've Advanced really the basic
physics understanding so far that we
have got the predictive capabilities but
we also have uh alignment with policy
and science drivers that we didn't
really have before that's I think what
can get us there maybe a demonstration
of net electricity in a decade is that
the thing folks are pushing for
we're pushing for it yeah there are
challenges still to overcome us you know
and hopefully we find solutions to those
when we have new experiments and when we
actually push forward yeah the potential
is huge
Fusion Energy Research is an
extraordinarily exciting field that is
pushing the frontiers of what we can do
experimentally as well as what we can do
computationally Fusion might be closer
than we think and tremendous advances
are being made every day
thank you